watch
the demilio show it's a show
about charlie dimigio a very sweet
young girl perhaps medicated i don't
know
but very calm and her family she's got
more followers on tick tock than people
exist on earth you know reality tv
should be fun and you realize how good
the kardashians were let me this thing
is so
boring that family will be in the
kitchen they'll be like making dinner
and then one of the girls goes
the internet said i should kill myself
again
and then the parents are like well
that's hey
that's not nice people are saying that i
should be dead today
but instead of dying i uploaded a dance
video and the parents like well if this
isn't good for the kids
we'll get out of here
and the kids are literally like today
someone else said i should be burned
alive if any if at any moment me and my
wife think it's a bad idea
for millions of people to tell my
daughter to kill herself
on the internet we'll move out of here
we'll go back to connecticut i used to
sell uh shorts
he's like
he sold athleisure where if the older
sister killed the younger sister
ramsay style
jonbenet
ramsey stop then we'll do season two
i just have ways to make it better the
father has to cheat on the mother with
it and start banging an 18 year old tick
docker dixie has to start dating o.j
simpson
charlie has to start starting fires in
malibu with homeless people if dixie was
singing to oj and the song is called
second chances and she's like second
chances
second chances and then oj's in the back
just like yeah and charlie's like
dixie's really killing it you know then
the father has to still say that he
still has to say that once everything's
crazy he doesn't mean like dixie's
dating o.j right she's having oj's baby
charlie's in jail for lighting in the
malibu fire and the father has to look
at the camera and go you know if it ever
gets too much i'll just take him back to
connecticut
if it ever gets too much
but we're gonna get through it together
as a family